The talk of governmentmandated gun-free
zones continues a pace this week as
another terrible tragedy, a murder of an
ROC instructor at Old Dominion
University, which is a state school in
Virginia,
is now again raising to the front of the
conversation in America is how on earth
can we have gun-free zones that do
nothing but stop law- abiding innocent
Americans from defending themselves
against the evil evil that lurks among
us, including apparently a Sierra
Leonborn immigrant brought to America
who now supports ISIS and of course
killed an hero, a veteran and an RTC
instructor at Old Dominion University.
And by the way, as our friends over
there at News2A, if you're not following
News2A, the website for gun related and
second amendment related news on X and
otherwise, check out their website. They
did an excellent job of reporting. Check
it out right here. Pointing out that Old
Dominion University had a gun, not only
a gun-free zone policy, but a
weapons-free zone policy. No weapons
allowed. which is quite interesting
because the way the students in the ROC
class took down the ISIS supporting
immigrant from Sierra Leon who was
killing people was they took him down
and killed him with a knife which
apparently would have violated Old
Dominion University's policy on no
weapons allowed. Nevertheless, we are
bringing on Stephen How to talk about
the constitutionality and some of the
legal analysis that goes in to
identifying what can legally and
constitutionally be a governmentmandated
gun-free zone at places like state
universities such as Old Dominion
University. And without further ado,
let's turn to my discussion with Steven
Halbrook about the notion of sensitive
places, the historical basis of
government government mandated gun-free
zones and related topics right here and
right now. Well, Stephen, while we have
you, I just want to talk to a couple
Second Amendment issues, specifically
the notion of sensitive places. Now,
sensitive places, as you're quite
familiar, is really just a euphemism for
governmentmandated gun-free zones. And I
know that over on the bullet conspiracy,
which if people are not reading your
work on the bullet conspiracy, they
should definitely check you out. You
often have articles over there, little
opeds and whatnot, which are always
great. uh you've done a lot of writing
recently about so-called sensitive
places which is basically an area where
uh the government can ban firearms and
and you've looked at some of the
historical research done by some
historians and you of course are one of
the foremost experts and historians when
it comes to the right to bear arms in
America you know how do we kind of
understand how do ordinary people
understand this notion of sensitive
places which is kind of a phrase that
came out of the Heler decision in 2008
and was kind of reaffirmed in brewin uh
where they articular ulate a couple
different examples of sensitive places.
Polling places at the time of the
founding, legislative chambers at the
time of the founding, cour houses at the
time of the founding. What is sort of
the way to think about this and what
does the historical record show us about
what these things meant at the time of
the founding in 1791 when the second
amendment was ratified?
>> Well, if if you start with Heler, um
sensitive places was not an issue in
Heler. The only issue was whether the
second amendment protects individual
rights and and whether the government
could ban mere possession of a handgun
in your home. Uh but it it was the first
really thorough second amendment
decision by the Supreme Court and
Justice Scalia wrote in that decision
that there are certain restrictions like
um bans on fire and possession in
schools and government buildings that
are presumptively
legal or lawful. Now presumptively means
yes probably but not necessarily. you
can rebut presumptions in the law. Um,
and maybe you can rebut part of a
presumption like maybe you could ban
guns by pupils in schools but not by
teachers or I mean there there it was
just a dicta in the decision uh because
it was you know there were other aspects
of second amendment that were being
discussed by the court and it was not
the issue in the case. And then we get
to brewin and as you just mentioned the
court uh said that well the kinds of
government buildings where guns could be
banned we don't know of any issues
uh whether we don't know that it's
disputed but that you can ban them in
polling places legislative assemblies
and courouses
and if you look at
what happens in those places I mean
courous is I think the best example of
all because people they they go to
court, they know what's there. You have
baist, you have guards. Um you have the
government actually taking over
security. Uh if you have comprehensive
security in courouses,
then you don't have as much of a need to
have a gun for self-defense, for
example, or another kind of weapon. And
so the the basis of um saying that these
could be sensitive places, these three
institutions is that traditionally or
historically at the founding you had
comprehensive security being provided in
them like uh polling places. You had in
Maryland in every county you had the
county sheriff had to be there at the
polling place. They didn't want people
uh political disruptors coming in and
intimidating people. The same with
legislative assemblies. You know, back
in the Truman administration, you had
Puerto Rican nationalists come and uh
try to shoot up the Congress. Uh you
have to have security in these places.
You have people with political
disagreements or in court. You have
criminals getting sentenced. You have um
a lot of reasons to have armed security.
If if it's to a true sensitive place,
you've got to have
security being provided by the
government, not just the ability like if
if if you try to say some uh you know
300 acre park is a sensitive place and
oh well you can call 911 if if
somebody's trying to rape you. That
doesn't get it. That's not security. And
yet we have jurisdictions enacting gun
bans at places like you know large
wooded acres of parkland or um
beaches
um a lot of outdoor places and then
indoor places as well. I mean, there's a
Supreme Court case that's pending right
now, Wolfford, which has been argued,
and there you have the state of Hawaii
saying that uh you can't carry a gun
into a a premises that's open to the
public unless they put a sign out
inviting you, which businesses don't
want to get involved in politics. Um,
so,
>> so Stephen, at the time of the founding
though, you know, because the Breuan
decision says, as Heler basically said
as well, although Breuan was more
explicit about it, uh, once a right to
keep and bear arms is implicated by
modern day regulation, you know, it's
infringed upon, restricted, hindered,
whatever you want to call it,
implicated. Um, the BMS shift to the
government to show a historical record,
a historical tradition of fires
regulation. So if you go back to 1791,
uh what was the historical tradition of
protecting uh at the time of our
founding courouses for example, did they
have baiffs back then? Um legislative
chambers, did they have sergeant-at-arms
at the time of the founding? Uh same
with polling places because remember at
the in the 18th century, as I recall,
Stephen, you're the historian here. Uh
but at the 18th century all the way up
until basically the end of the 19th
century voting in America was not
confidential. It was not private. We
don't move to the Australian ballot
until the end of the 19th century. Which
means when you're voting for George
Washington and all these offices at the
time of the founding guess what uh your
vote is public. You have to declare who
you're voting for. This speaks to the
notion of that voting is not really a
personal fundamental individual right so
much. it really is more of a civic duty
like serving on a jury. So can you speak
to what the historical record uh is at
the time of the founding in terms of uh
protecting these places the Supreme
Court identified legislative chambers,
courouses and polling places which again
at the time uh everyone knew who how you
voted which is much different than today
in the 21st century
>> right um polling places is a good
example. I like to talk about uh
Delaware in that regard. And the reason
why you had enhanced security at polling
places and you had gunbands at at
polling places was that [clears throat]
like uh some of the other colonies
during the revolution,
you had um horrible disagreements
between patriots and tries. Um you had a
lot of killings, burning of houses. Um
it was it was a pretty terrible
situation.
And after the revolution ended, you
still had a lot of political
disagreements. You had state laws
restricting firearms at polling places
in in that state. Um
now the the fact that the Supreme Court
identified polling places as a sensitive
area um where guns could be prohibited,
it doesn't necessarily imply that today
every state has such a law or that um
there's armed security at every polling
place. I know I vote at an elementary
school library and there's no security
there. I'm not aware that there's a law
against going armed there either. But um
if the government's really serious, if
if there if they think that a place
needs to be gun-free, it's not going to
be gun-free unless they provide enhanced
security. And I I I think courouses is
the most obvious example. Um
I think there's always been armed
security of one kind or another at at
courouses. And in fact in English
history you you had the specific going
arms statute which went back to um 1326
statute of Northampton. Um
and the way it was interpreted you you
couldn't go armed to the terror of the
people um but you could not go before
the king's justices armed. And so you
have a long tradition where
you know courts are doing some pretty
serious business and uh you you've got
people
charged with murder or you've got all
kinds of uh things going on. You have
people getting divorces and they're
really mad at each other. So you you've
got a lot of reasons that motivated
legislators to ban guns at courouses but
also to provide very very good security.
I mean, if you go to a typical
courthouse,
um, typically there'll be the sheriff's
department will be in charge and they'll
have deputies. There will be, uh, each
courtroom will have, uh, a deputy or a
baleiff of some kind. So, um, and with
legislative chambers, it's it's the same
thing. And there's plenty of historical
examples. You mentioned a there's a a
recent study by Dr. Angus Mlelen.
uh if you want to just Google his name
with the word sensitive places, you'll
find it. Um he he's done a study of the
historical uh examples where throughout
the original states in the period of
when the bill of rights was um adopted,
you had um comprehensive security at
those places that the court identifies
in ruin.
>> Orders up. Table 2 A.